Salut à tous, c'est Pécheur de Trésor.
J'espère que vous allez bien
Vous reconnaissez surement Leigh de la chaîne Bondi Treasure Hunter.
Bonjour.
Avec Nicky qui est aussi là.
On est là pour la partie 2 de Pêche à l'aimant en France lors de leur voyage.
Ce va perdre maintenant, c'est qu'on va jeter les aimants.
Ok.
Prêt ?
Je suis prêt.
Aimant lancé !
Allez c'est parti.
Voyons voir ce qu'il y a sous ce pont.
Moi j'ai quelque chose.
Une ceinture non ?
Je ne sais pas.
C'est quoi ?
Ah c'est une sangle.
La pue
Une sangle.
Ouais.
Ouais une sangle.
Ah là l'odeur elle est horrible aujourd'hui.
Ouais.
J'ai quelque chose.
Ah non c'est un morceau de scooter.
Suspension de scooter.
Oh, ca vient d'une moto
Oui d'une moto
J'ai appelé le chien " Hatchi"
Ah non.
Oh, qu'est-ce que c'est ça ?
Un objet vaseux
Je ne sais pas ce que c'est.
Je ne sais pas.
Mais il pue
C'est pas comme un morceau de scooter ?
On dirait qu'il y a un cadenas
Comme un cadenas oui
Ouais.
Je pense qu'il y aura plus de ceci là-bas.
On viens juste commencer et j'aime déjà cet endroit
Oh, un moteur.
Regarde comme cet objet est vaseux et noir
Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
Qu'est-ce que c'est mon pote ?
Je ne sais pas.
Je ne sais pas non plus
C'est bizarre
Il est resté dans la vase trop longtemps
Oh, il a un câble attaché
C'est comme un moteur.
C'est un pot non ?
Un pot d'échappement ?
Ouais.
Il me paraît un peu épais quand même
Peut-être que Quentin devrait aller dans l'eau.
Non, non.
Ouais, je le recommande.
Non, non, non, non.
Il y a quelque chose juste ici
Regardez les bulles
Regardez.
C'est massive.
Bondi a quelque chose de gros, là.
J'ai besoin d'un autre aimant ici
Oui.
Ok, j'arrive
On est en mode broussaille
Là-bas.
Je vais essayer.
Peut-être un peu plus de ce côté
Il y a quelque chose de gros la dessous
Oui, c'est grand.
Je suis dessus
Tu es dessus ?
Ok.
Je suis dessus aussi
Ok, vas-y.
Là, il vient.
Oh, c'est là-bas.
Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
Je pense que c'est une moto
Oh, oui, oui, oui.
C'est une grosse
Oui.
Ok, vas-y.
Oh, regardez le cadre
Regarde ça.
C'est cadre de moto
Ouais.
Et c'est tellement vaseux ici que c'est difficile à sortir du canal.
Regarde ça.
Vous m'aviez prévenu que c'était un spot de criminels
Oui, oui, oui.
Ok, cool.
Bien joué.
Allez on va continuer alors
C'est un bon signe
Quentin, regarde ce que je viens de trouver.
Vous avez besoin de bottes ?
Oh, j'ai besoin de bottes
Un silencieux, en bon état
Ok.
Il faut être gentil avec ces mecs, ils ont un silencieux
On continue, je suis excité
Un silencieux.
Les gars, on a trouvé un silencieux !
C'est bon, ça.
C'est stylé !
Yeah.
Oh, my gosh.
Trouvons le reste
En plus, vu l'état, le gun, il serait vraiment nickel.
Moi, je part de la théorie que tu ne jettes pas un silencieux sans avoir jeté le gun.
Qu'est-ce que t'en penses ?
Après, le nombre de fois, on a trouvé des munitions sans l'arme
Ouais, des fois, c'est vrai.
On ne trouve que des parties.
Mais là, un silencieux, putain, il est comme neuf.
Incroyable.
Je ne pensais pas que c'étais si léger, tu vois.
Ben ouais, ouais.
Mais, tu vois, j'ai vu marqué "Unique"
Regardez ça.
Regardez cette ficelle
Il y a un bijou avec
Regarde ça.
C'est comme un bouton de manchette
Tu vois ?
C'est cool
C'est très français
Regarde ça.
C'est cool, mec.
C'est cool.
C'est bien Rasta
Regardez
Leigh a quelque chose.
Quentin, tu l'aides ?
En avant les francais !
Allons y ensemble.
Ouais, on va faire ça ensemble.
T'es prêt mon pote ?
OK, Baptiste, ouais.
Baptiste est en haut et il nous regarde
Descend ici mon pote
Oh, my gosh.
C'est coincé !
Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
Oh, my gosh.
On va faire ça d'un autre angle ?
Ouais, on va faire ça.
Non.
C'est venu et il s'est bloqué
Regardez ce beau spot avec les Pyrénées là-bas.
Non.
Allons de ce côté
C'est très vaseux
Ah, ouais.
Il faut qu'on saute sur les rochers là
Oh, my gosh.
C'est vivant !
Bon, Baptiste, c'est quoi ? C'est bizarre
Ouais, c'est très bizarre.
Il y a des bouts qui remontent
Super bizarre.
Bon, bah là, on va essayer de repasser au-dessus du pont.
On n'arrive vraiment pas à le sortir.
Regardez-moi la couleur de ses pâtes.
Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
Mais là, c'est un rocher qu'on voit ?
Non, non.
Ça fait partie de l'objet.
OK.
Il est coincé
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, du coup, c'est juste un vieux panneau, hein ?
C'est un vieux panneaux de circulation
Oui, oui.
C'est un gros.
Là, on y va.
Il dit "Bonjour, bienvenue en France"
Ouais.
Bon, bah sympa.
Beau panneau quand même.
Ouais, c'est du panneau de compétition.
Vous devez le ramener chez vous pour compléter votre collection
Oui.
Vous allez le faire ?
Oui, on va le faire
Il va sentir tellement bon dans camion utilitaire
Ca sent déjà très bon
Oui.
C'est une magnifique aventure.
Ca va bien mon pote ?
OK.
Toujours en train de pêcher à l'aimant sous ce pont
où on a trouvé un silencieux.
Il y a quelques trucs qui sont bien aimantés
mais à chaque fois, ils ne viennent pas.
Là, l'idéal se serait de descendre dans la vase
mais je vous avoue qu'elle a eu une odeur.
Ça ne donne vraiment pas envie.
Regardez cette petite technique.
J'hésité à aller dans l'eau.
Je crois que je vais y aller
Si y a un moment, un endroit où il faut aller dans l'eau, c'est là
Bon, j'en ai marre.
Il y a plein de gros objets qui ne viennent pas.
Donc je vais y aller.
Même si que c'est complètement dégueulasse et que l'eau pu.
Et que c'est que le début de la journée
que je vais devoir garder mes pieds tout mouillés.
Il est temps d'y aller
Ça fait plaisir à Bondi
Ça fait plaisir à Leigh
De la chaîne Bondi Treasure Hunter
Qui ne vient pas souvent.
Et c'est pour faire une grosse dédicace à Wim aussi.
Notre ami néerlandais avec qui on pêche souvent
qui lui adore aller dans la vase.
Wim, je n'ai pas encore ton talent
Mais je vais essayer de faire au mieux.
J'en profite pour passer une dédicace à à un Neddy de la part d'Alexandre et Thibault
Voilà, je vais dans l'eau pour vous.
Elle est froide?
Regardez le noir qui remonte
La taille de la vase est comme ça
Oh mon Dieu.
Peut-être que tu n'as pas pied
Oh mon Dieu, il est là.
Là, t'es dessus
Tu le sent mon pote ?
Oui.
Il l'a !
Je pense que je peux l'attacher
Oh, ok.
Nice.
Ok.
Non mon pote ! Ne va pas sous l'eau
Super
Essayons de tirer
Donc là, on a pris le treuil
parce qu'il est impossible de tirer ce que Baptiste a attaché.
Ok, donc ils installent le treuil.
Moi je vais bouger de là.
Oh, j'ai vu des bulles
Je vois des bulles
Il bouge
Je pense que c'est bon
Il est vient, il vient
Oui.
Très bien
C'est quoi ça ?
C'est un grand cadre de scooter
Oh mon Dieu.
Bien joué
Bien joué mon pote
Bien !
Regardez, les gars.
Ça y est, ils sortent le cadre de scooter.
Vous imaginez le poids.
Il doit soulever ça d'en haut.
Je leur aurais bien donné un coup de main, mais je ne peux pas.
Regardez ça.
C'est très lourd.
Je m'en doutais que c'était un cadre de scooter.
Je pense que tu as le bon travail Baptiste.
Non, ça valait le coup, ça valait le coup.
Ok.
Bien joué mon frère.
Bien
Bien joué.
Je n'arrive plus à parler
Une journée sportive
On a plein de plastique avec.
Oh my gosh.
Bon bah belle trouvaille.
Regardez, si vous savez quel cadre de scooter c'est en commentaires, dites le nous.
Bon là, ils vont continuer à lancer les aimants pour repérer les objets.
Et moi, je vais essayer de les attacher dès qu'il y en a des nouveaux.
Allez essayez de les trouver
C'est très gros
Ok je vais l'attacher
Ça vient.
Alors on a eu quelque chose en plein milieu.
Bondi !
A fond !
Oh, c'est un caddie de courses
Ouais.
Donc c'est bien un caddie.
S'en est un petit
Mon dieu...
Oh, l'odeur...
Vous voyez dans quoi je suis en train de marcher.
Là-bas, il y avait environ 50 centimètres de vase, c'est n'importe quoi.
Rasta dit bonjour à la voiture....
Rasta.
Allez jouer tous les deux
Ah, c'est parce qu'il y a un chien là, ok.
Ouais, c'est pour ça.
Le copain.
Joli lancé
Et regardez ça.
La pêche pêche
Oh non, le pauvre.
Ça a frappé un Rasta sauvage au lasso.
Et ça y est, il est tout noir maintenant.
Bon, celui-là, je le sors là-là.
Oh non, ouais.
T'as fait la giclée sur Rasta
Pardon.
Yeah.
Voilà donc, sorti de cette eau dégueulasse.
Bon, regardez quand même tout ce qu'on a réussi à sortir.
Donc ça va aller le coup de descendre.
Ouais.
Pas fait pour rien.
On va enlever le morceau de béton parce qu'on ne veut pas ramener ça au ferrailleur
Ouais.
On va faire ça avec la disqueuse Ecoflow.
Non, pas la disqueuse, la batterie Ecoflow.
La batterie Ecoflow.
Merci Ecoflow pour cette batterie qui nous est bien utile.
Ok.
Nice.
Ouais, c'est bon.
C'est la fin de cette vidéo de pêche à l'aimant
Donc, c'était super avec bondy.
Ouais, un grand merci Leigh
Ouais.
Merci.
N'hésitez pas à aller voir sa chaîne.
Elle est en description.
Ouais, bien sûr.
Vous avez toutes les infos, il parcourt toute l'Europe.
Il fait de la pêche à l'aimant et il plonge aussi parfois.
Il trouve beaucoup d'or.
Ouais.
Beaucoup de bijoux
De l'or
Et un fusil sniper
A la prochaine
Ouais.
C'est l'antivole intégré au scooter.
Ouais, on dirait.
Ouais.
Qui n'a pas servi
On le rentre ?
Allez, on rentre.
Ok.